there's another study that came out that
only 12 percent or maybe 12.2
or 3 of americans are metabolically
healthy
that means 88 of us are not
metabolically healthy which means we
have high blood sugar high blood
pressure
high cholesterol or have belly fat right
88 percent of us so even if we're thin
you know about 20 to 40 percent of
people who are thin if you i
junk food i'm not getting weight what's
the matter i can eat sugar no on the
inside
you may be just as bad as someone who's
obese you just can't tell from the
outside
i believe that each and every one of us
has the power within ourselves
to create the life that we really want
and i want to help give you the tools to
make that happen i'm danica patrick
and i'm pretty intense on the show today
is dr
mark hyman he is a physician and 13-time
best-selling author he has a new book
out this year called
food fix we talked about animal protein
we talked about sugar
we talked about protein powders soil
health you know what is happening to our
food before it gets to us
i think it's just important for us as a
culture that we start to
learn and understand what's going on out
there in the world that's
making us either well or unwell and he
is a deep sea of information when it
comes to that
i learned a lot and i know you will too
so
get into this episode and take your
notes enjoy
what i find the most exciting right now
is that so many people so many people
seem interested
in health and wellness are and are
becoming
more aware of natural modalities
and where their food comes from
and i'm just curious where you think
that that's coming from
i think we we are seeing the best and
the worst
right so we're seeing a movement of
people who are really health-focused
focusing on whole foods and eating
better and exercise and
spirituality meditation and focusing on
sleep and yet at the same time
we have a pandemic of chronic disease
that affects 6 out of 10 americans
75 percent of us are overweight 42
are obese including 40 of kids are
overweight
and and we've never seen this level of
disease so at the same time there's an
interesting health and wellness we're
also seeing this pandemic of disease so
i think they probably are feeding off
each other a little bit but i i think
we're in a very weird moment because we
now know more than ever
what to do to create health but at the
same time we're suffering under the
burden
of debilitating diseases that are
crippling
communities that are depriving people of
their vitality that are
leading them with huge burdens
economically from health care costs so
we're in a very unusual moment
but i i'm hopeful because i think there
there is a rise of awareness about
eating right and living well and how
important that is
and understand the connection between
what we eat and how we feel yeah
for sure well let's break it down like
let's break down
why there's such polarity right now
in out there in the world there's people
there's children that are obese there's
people dying of heart disease and
anxiety and all kinds of crazy things
right now and then of course there's the
other side that are
you know into you know organics in their
own garden and adaptogens and meditation
and so i i kind of i'm curious like
let's start with let's start with the
worst news first
like why are we over here on this this
side of
people dying from not taking care of
themselves well that's a great question
i
i wrote a book recently called food fix
how to save our health our economy our
communities and our planet one bite at a
time trying to connect the dots for
people
helping them understand why we're in
this situation we're not just in terms
of our chronic disease burden but
why is our economy strained under the
cost of health care why are we seeing
communities
suffering so much from the burdens of
disease and and this and
disparities in health why are we seeing
our environment and our climate being
you know really uh burdened through
through um
you know both environmental destruction
and increasing carbon in the environment
so how do we address all these things as
one problem
well it turns out they're all connected
by food and and you know while there
were good
intentions after world war ii to create
a robust agricultural system that
produced a lot of food for a lot of
people with a lot of calories
and feed a hungry starving growing world
we really didn't understand the
unintended consequences of doing that
the way we did it which was to grow
large amounts of starchy calories
wheat corn and you know soy obviously
too
and doing it with agricultural methods
that were extremely destructive and
extractive
you know we didn't know pesticides were
bad we didn't know fertilizer was bad we
didn't know
that we damaged soil and that would lead
to carbon
in the environment that's basically no
people didn't know
better living through chemistry throwing
chemicals in the ground puts it in the
ingredients
not in the 1950s not 1940s and 50s
people had no idea
it wasn't until rachel carson wrote the
book silent spring in 1960 where she
connected the dots and showed how
ddt was devastating all kinds of animal
populations
and birds and i mean we've lost 50
percent of our bird species in america
because of the way we grow food yes
we've lost
from eating the food that's contained
that has so many chemicals in it
because we're spraying everything and
those yes as those you know those
chemicals affect the
the birds and and they're and they're
just not reproducing and they're having
you know eggs that don't form hard
shells i mean this
this is a really frightening thing
there's a book called our stolen future
that describes this
and you've got a very excited uh excited
fan there
my guard dog yeah and so i think i think
we really never understood that it was
bad it was you know the
modern progress the green revolution it
was you know industrialization and
and modernization it was a good thing
back in the 50s but we now know that
those those things which we did
unthinkingly
and thinking we were doing a good thing
actually trying to be a horrific thing
that we now produce
500 calories more per person in america
than we need to eat mostly in the form
of sugar and starch
which now we know drive diabetes obesity
and heart disease
and we do it in ways that are extremely
destructive to the environment
and lead to uh destruction of our soil
we have 60 harvests left
before we run out of soil because of
over tillage and the chemicals we put in
the soil that kill the microbiology in
the soil
frightening that's yeah yeah 60 60
harvest that's like you know that's
i'm maybe i'll be alive in 60 years i
don't know but you probably will be
and i mean like you know that is a that
is a lot not that far away and no
soil no food no humans we have water
resource
issues because of how we're irrigating
and using all the aquifers we're
showing biodiversity of of our plants i
mean we've lost 95 percent of our edible
plant species 50
of our livestock species and and again
75 percent of our pollinator species
which are necessary to pollinate
bees yeah bees and bees and birds and
you know like
butterflies and it's like so so and with
them and then we're destroying oceans
through the nitrogen runoff that kills
you know hundreds of thousands of metric
tons of fish every year in the gulf of
mexico and there's
you know 400 of these dead zones so
we've created this massive destructive
agricultural system that produces
food that's bad for us that harms the
planet and it needs to stop and
and i think we're not only waking up to
this fact
and i'm really encouraged because
there's a whole movement of regenerative
agriculture regenerative health which is
really about
rethinking how we're doing things and
the good news is the good news is that
by actually focusing on
the farm and the seed and the way we
grow food we can produce better food
it's more nutrient dense that restores
the environment that makes farmers more
money
that puts carbon in the soil instead in
the atmosphere and really can be the
biggest carbon sink on the planet
you know bigger than any other
technology for solving climate change
can conserve water and increase
biodiversity bring back all kinds of
species of animals and plants
so it's a really solution
but but it needs to scale and so i think
you know i was at a
conference this week where we discussed
you know how do we scale up regenerative
agriculture because it really is the key
and how do we link agriculture and
health care together and
understand that food is medicine and
then that we really should be focusing
on that
so i think that's i i think we're in
this pivotal moment where we're starting
to hear about it
and it's being talked about and and it's
very exciting
well you mentioned that it could be
more financially beneficial yeah
yeah because if you're you know
my opinion would be that the reason why
it's still going is because way too many
people make money
yes not the farmers
no okay so not the farmers this is the
big corporations
yeah so here's how it works so so the
farmers
are the middlemen they're squeezed in
the middle between the banks which loan
the money
to buy their crop seeds and to buy the
chemicals
the banks make them buy crop insurance
from the government which then gives
them crop insurance
basically a subsidy then they go and
they buy the seed and the chemicals from
the agricultural companies
so they're just they're just a middleman
between the bank and the common these
big agricultural
seed and chemical companies then they
squeeze out a little bit of
production from their farm and the
average farmer
makes less than minus sixteen hundred
dollars a year
and they have all this debt they have
all this machinery they're stuck in this
vicious cycle
their farms are degrading they're losing
soil they're not resilient to droughts
and floods
their their productivity goes down and
when you look at farmers like gabe brown
who was a north dakota farmer whose farm
was decimated from
hail and bad weather and storms and that
he decided to you know change his way of
farming he read thomas jefferson's
journals
and learned about all sorts of
techniques of farming that were
regenerative and restorative that
actually helped heal the earth and build
soil and so he started using these ideas
and now he's he literally uses no input
so no chemicals seeds
he no no pesticides herbicides
fertilizer
he follows the principles of
regenerative agriculture he
he's resilient to droughts and floods
every percent organic matter he adds to
soil he holds 27 000 gallons of water so
when his farmer's
in a drought uh he's doing fine when the
farmer has a flood
his soil holds all the water so it
doesn't flood
he draws down carbon through the soil
which is 29 inches of soil he's built
over the last
decades using this technology which
takes literally thousands and thousands
of years to do without that
i believe that everyone should
experience what better feels like
that's why i love beam cbd i'm an
investor
and i swear by beams products which
combine
thc free cbd with other high quality
ingredients
theme was founded by two former
professional athletes
matt and kevin and they just dropped
a new product called focus it's a daily
capsule that helps boost your focus
all day long so visit beamtlc.com and
use the promo code
pretty intense for 15 off your next
purchase
that's beamtlc.com and he makes 20
times 20 times the amount of money as
his neighbor
and he produces food that has
far more nutrients oh yeah than the
other food
because of the way the soil provides and
extracts nutrients from the soil to the
plants
including the animals the animals are
more nutrient dense
because the animals are eating hundreds
of species of different
grasses the cows and so those grasses
all have medicines in them
phytochemicals
and they end up in the in the animal
products so actually you could be
eating the equivalent amount of
beneficial compounds you can green tea
by having
animals that ate certain plants so this
is an incredible area of science
that's emerging and it's it's just so
exciting because
we've seen a decline of about 50 percent
of nutrient density in their food
and basic minerals and other nutrients
even if you're eating broccoli and you
think you're doing well for yourself and
you're eating junk food
it's 50 less nutritious than it was 50
years ago
you have to eat 50 do you have to eat
twice as much then
yeah good luck with that i tried to i've
occasionally binged on broccoli
i actually growing broccoli in my garden
and i went to picked a whole bunch
because it was going to go
you know to see it so i had to eat it
and i was like oh yeah i think i ate too
much broccoli
yeah you're like i'm gonna go be over
here in this other room
[Laughter]
my gosh you said making 20 times more
than his neighbor
yes i mean unfortunately i feel like
money drives so much of this so when you
say that it must
to as if i'm a farmer i'm thinking sign
me up how do you do that how the heck is
he making so much more
who is he is he because he produces more
is it
yeah so he he yes yes yes yes and yes so
one he doesn't have to buy all the input
so he's not buying seeds he's not buying
pesticides he's not buying fertilizer
he's not buying herbicides right
second he's he's actually um
getting more money for his crops because
it's a higher value-add product
and he also um is able to sort of avoid
this trap of all this debt that's going
on with all these farmers who have to be
beholden to the banks and
have all the all these incredible debts
and so
he's really able to do this and he's
shown with his colleagues uh
through something called the soil health
academy which is an incredible training
group of farmers who are training other
farmers around the country
to do this and they said you know these
farmers don't know how to do it and
they're nervous and
they've been farming the old way for so
long he said they teach them how to do
this
and in one year they're profitable in
the first year they're profitable
so i think there's a there's a real need
to incentivize
farmers to do this and the reason i care
so much about this as a doctor
is because i care about the food my
patients eat because the food is making
them sick
and if we get on the right food they're
going to help get healthy so the
solution to our health care crisis
really starts on the farm
yeah clearly okay now on the other side
of the spectrum
right so that's like those are i mean
why
what what woke us up
uh i don't know how many of us are awake
but i i think there's
you know there's people like you and i
who are on this train and there there
are a lot of our followers who are
but there's still a large swath of
americans who are pretty um
disconnected from from what is is good
and healthy not not because they don't
want to be
but because there's such a mass of
marketing and education i mean
the average kid sees you know 10 000 ads
on
tv for junk food and a year facebook put
a bill
half a billion half a no sorry
500 billion facebook had 500 billion
ads for junk food for kids targeted art
kids and this is not stuff that even
parents are aware of they're like
micro targeting these kids and we can't
compete with that
and it's everywhere it's in schools it's
on street corners it's in the bodegas
it's at the checkout counter
it's it's like a food carnival that is
driving so much of our
suffering and i think we we we really
don't learn about it in school
our government doesn't do a good job of
providing dietary guidelines that are
science-based
you know we have food programs like snap
that are
earnest food stamps that don't have any
nutrition guidelines within them so you
can buy soda
junk food in fact ten percent of snap
dollars are spent for soda that's seven
billion a year
which is which is about 30 billion
servings of soda to the poor
so basically you know maybe so coca-cola
is one of the biggest welfare recipients
in the in the country billions of
dollars going to their bottom line
because of a government spending on soda
so we kind of have a screwed up system
and i think uh there are there are
people who are
uh becoming aware and there is a
movement in regenerative agriculture
there's a movement of people who are
health conscious and i think
you know it's growing significantly over
time and i and i really like to see that
because it will move the culture like
everything else
i have this theory that if if a company
has enough it's like a
you know not proven or anything but in
my mind if if there's a company that has
enough money to advertise
i probably shouldn't buy it
that's a great idea well it depends on a
lot of i've spent a lot of my life being
paid by people like that
you know i don't do it anymore but i
mean that was
that's the way racing world was you know
yeah and your nascar you know uniform
was like a big advertisement right
it's like yeah and some i mean i had a
lot of great sponsors over the years
don't get me wrong but
you know there have been a few along the
way that i'm like doesn't fit
yeah right but they have money to
advertise that's true
no it's true i think there are good
companies out there doing good things
but uh you know and i think there's a
whole moving toward b corporations which
are
corporations that are you know in
integrity with
their values around how they treat their
customers and theirs their
employees and all the stakeholders and
you know i see stuff
changing you know the business
roundtable which is some of the top
companies in the world get together and
in the last gathering they had they said
we should not just focus on value for
our shareholders but on our stakeholders
which includes
our employees our customers the earth
everything you know what who
who's a stakeholder and that's a these
are big shifts in thinking so i do
see change happening i really do but
it's it's not fast enough for me
of course well especially if you're
practicing a different way than
a great majority of the of the
population is
is there been anything that has really
shifted or turned or been flipped upside
down
with everything that's going on with
2020
um well yeah i mean for me
yeah pretty much everything let's just
hit reset on it you know can we just hit
a reboot on the year
let's start january again it would seem
to be such a positive thing 2020 and
clear vision and you know uh you know
wow
but maybe it is maybe it is helping us
see things that we never
saw before so there's a few things that
have really been exposed particularly in
my world
uh one is was the fragility of our food
system and the centralization of our
food system we saw with the meat packing
plants and
you know empty shelves i think the real
fragility when you have a huge
centralization of food processing
and food packaging and food production
and and and the need for a more
distributed decentralized
you know model that is more stable
and sustainable is a really important
thing the second thing that's happened
it's really was unfortunate
but it's really become clear that the
people who are most susceptible to covet
19 are those who are sick
those who are older those who are
overweight and these are diseases that
are really driven by diet
so 80 of chronic disease which is what's
killing people
with covet 19 is caused by diet obesity
is a huge risk factor for for severe
illness and death because these people
are pre-inflamed
and the diets we're eating are highly
inflammatory lots of sugar starch
processed food
all those are inflaming our bodies in
ways it makes kovid just so happy
and makes the body just overreact and
attack
and that creates this cytokine storm
which kills people and puts them in the
hospital
so if we were all really fit and healthy
uh and and really you know not one in
two of us weren't pre-diabetic
covert might just not be such a big deal
yeah
or two people and you said one and two
yeah one two it's actually even worse
than that
when you when you you know this is by
this the sort of criteria the
traditional criteria of pre-diabetes
which i think is very loose
so i think there's another study that
came out that only 12 percent or maybe
12.2 or 3
of americans are metabolically healthy
that means 88
of us are not metabolically healthy
which means we have high blood sugar
high blood pressure
high cholesterol or have belly fat right
88 of us so even if we're thin
you know about 20 to 40 percent of
people who are thin if you think
i junk food i'm not gaining weight
what's matter i can eat sugar
no on the inside you may be just as bad
as someone who's obese you just can't
tell from the outside
skinny skinny fat you look skinny but
you're fat nobody wants to be skinny
fat unless they're fat fat and then
that's even worse i guess but
i mean that's my dad like my dad's been
pre-diabetic for a while
and you know they i i mean i guess it
in in some way it's good that they get a
little scared
yeah i mean you know you know people
need the motivation but
if you're living in an environment
that's a toxic food wasteland
uh where there's really no food there's
only food like substances
very hard to change when every every
where you go it's hard to make the right
choice the easy choice is the wrong
choice and the hard choice is the right
choice and i think we need to change
that and make it
more accessible and easy i think that's
that's really what's happening i think
there's
there's really a movement towards this
but it's it's tough
i think there's also some rebellion
there's some cognitive dissonance on the
whole situation
because like my dad has plenty of
availability to healthy food i mean i'm
all over the place my sister my mom me
and information
and um and still the choices get made
that aren't the aren't the smartest
choices
and so i think there's people too that
also you know this comes in
this is the met the mind frame the
mental space of really believing that
there's
um that it's the right thing to do and i
want to get to that because that to me
is like
other modalities of health other than
just the pureness of what you put in
your mouth
but um but let's talk about that i mean
you know you've
you've written plenty of books and
helped millions of people
you know take better care of themselves
so you know there's
there's some topics i have curiosity on
and i'm guessing other people do too
and so you know you uh you can be blunt
for sure i love the truth in the most
direct way
but there's definitely some curiosities
so like the first one that comes to mind
for me with
with um my diet that i've str i've
i would say struggled with been confused
about gone back and forth and this this
whole debate
in my head and in the public about
animal protein
and you know the the purity of veganism
right and not
you know the cruelty to animals and and
it's and it's never been the flavor
that's the problem it's always been the
ethics of it all
right yeah you know but you know
understanding also that there's a
feeling behind
how you feel when you consume things too
so
you know maybe the first question is how
much protein do we really need
well the i think the question is really
do we need animal protein
or plant protein or both and how much do
we need
and and i think you know you you just
open the can of worms pandora's box
of meat and i just want to dive in there
for a second
if you let me because i've studied this
i've studied this
extensively because i want to look to be
120 and i don't want to be eating meat
if it's going to kill me and i i have
focused on the science of creating
health for the last 30 years and i've
studied it and not just studied it but
i've been practicing treating tens of
thousands of patients
and it's very humbling you can read all
these articles you want you can
you know go to these lectures you want
you can listen all these experts that
you want but when you're in a room with
a person day after day and you're seeing
the changes that happen when they eat
this diet or that diet
it just it makes you humble to
understand we're all different with that
said there are really three issues
around meat the first is moral and
ethical
the second is environmental right and
climate and the third is health
and they often get conflated into one
issue right
uh if it's morally bad it's bad for your
health it's about the environment well
well the truth is
if you are a buddhist monk or you have
ethical objections
or religious objections to eating
animals i totally honor that and respect
that and that's a
that's a very good life choice for you
if that's what you believe in you want
it's important to understand that you
can't escape killing things
being a human being on the planet even
if you're eating carrots
you are destroying the habitat of so
many animals
right so just just animal i mean for
vegetable plant agriculture kills seven
billion
animals a year rabbits moles
birds right insects all this i mean if
you can't insects probably more
but but i think we can't get away from
it so you might not be directly eating
it but
you know if if a rabbit gets you know
mowed down
as they're you know picking the
vegetables
is that any less of an issue than
a cow being slaughtered for human
consumption i don't know it's just a
question you should think about
so that's the first issue the second
issue is environmental and climate and i
think this is really unfortunate because
it gets dichotomized into
the only way to save the planet is to be
vegan because
animal agriculture animal industrial
agriculture
is causing climate change and it's a
false conversation because
cafes or confined animal feeding
operations are
horrible they're they're horrible for
the animals in terms of their treatment
they're horrible for the environment and
drive climate change and
amazing environmental destruction and
they're
bad for us the quality of the meat is
bad
however that doesn't mean that all meat
is bad if you look at for example wild
animals
or we're generally raised animals
very different so for example if you
look at a regeneratively raised
cow some some people said you know it's
not the cow it's the how
you know if you take a regeneratively
raised cow which is grown in a way that
is on in
open grasslands it's it's treated very
well it moves around in a herd-like
fashion in a way that actually builds
soil they eat
lots and lots of different plants so
they're the nutritional density of their
food
is very high they're less inflammatory
or actually maybe anti-inflammatory
you know i mean there's one study of a
kangaroo is in
a lot of kangaroo meat in australia so
they actually they actually measured
people's levels of inflammation eating
kangaroo meat
you know ounce per ounce compared to a
feedlot meat and the feedlot meat raised
people's levels of inflammation whereas
the kangaroo meat reduced
the inflammation right so it's it's
really depending on what you're eating
and in term in terms of you know
environment the only way to really
draw down enough carbon to take us out
of the disaster of this climate change
is to build soil it is the biggest
carbon capture
technology on the planet it can store
three times the amount of carbon that's
in the atmosphere right now
30 to 40 percent of all the carbon in
the atmosphere now is not coming from
fossil fuels
it's coming from loss of soil carbon
because of the destructive agricultural
methods that till it up they use
chemicals that destroy the soil
so using animals to build
soil can actually draw down the carbon
and actually some say that it may even
be enough to stop climate change for 20
years according to the u.n
if we take five of the five million
degraded acres of land hectares of land
around the world and we took two million
of those and we
spent 300 billion dollars to turn into
regenerative agriculture we could stop
climate change for 20 years
now 300 billion seems like a lot of
money but it's basically less than
medicare spends on diabetes
you know it's it's it's less than two
months of military spending around the
world
it's about the economy of chile every
year
so i mean i think i think we actually
have the ability to do this we've spent
what i don't know what was it
three four five trillion dollars on
coveted recovery i mean 300 billion is a
rounding error on that and yet we could
do that
so so i think from the environmental
issues um it's really important to
understand that
it's almost impossible to really solve
climate change without
using animals in an integrated way in a
regenerative way on the farm and
eliminating
factory formed animals now that doesn't
mean you have to eat it if you're
morally opposed you don't have to eat it
but they're they're a necessary part of
restoring ecosystems
and the third issue is health this is
where it gets really sticky because
i've written whole books on this but
it's but essentially
you know we're told that animal protein
is going to kill you
and it's based on very poor data and
there's contradictory data so you
no matter what side you're on you can
literally find a plethora of studies to
prove that meat is healthy
and a plethora of studies to show that
meat's going to kill you right
who do you believe right and and most of
these studies are what we call
observational studies so
the the big mean studies that show
they're so harmful were what we do
we call population studies so we'll
we'll we'll set a date and time let's
say 1970 and then we'll follow people
for 30 years and every year we'll ask
them a question here what did you eat
what did you eat which eat
and then we'll find out what they died
from and then we'll try to see if
there's a correlation
now um correlation studies
aren't proof they're not proving
anything they're just showing a
correlation
so for example um i could do a study of
women over 55 who had sex and i would
conclude that women
who had with sex would never lead to
pregnancy
right yeah right it's
true but it's kind of scientifically
relevant right
or or or are the studies that show
there's an increase show a just slight
increase so
it's also the degree of change with
these observational studies so smoking
you saw a 20-1 increase in the risk of
lung cancer
in smokers in these observational
studies that
you could take to the bank if it's
anything less than a two-fold increase
it's probably not so relevant it could
be just chance so most of the studies i
mean are like
up a 0.7 or
sorry 0.17 a 0.3 and they say that's a
30
increase right it's not a 2 000 increase
it's a you know so i think i think we
just
get all screwed up with the numbers and
then third a lot of these studies were
done at times when people were eating
while they were eating feedlot meat
they were eating terrible foods and the
meat eaters at the time were unhealthy
why because everybody knew that meat was
bad for you
back then we should cut out meat
saturated fat and so people who ate meat
didn't care about their health and when
you looked at their
their characteristics they smoked more
they drank more they ate more
they weighed more they ate less fruits
and vegetables they didn't take their
vitamins
of course they they had more heart
disease so was it the meat or something
else
and there's been large studies looking
at me there was a review of six
uh six different studies that were
published looking at you know hundreds
and hundreds of different trials
and found that there really was no
significant correlation and that was
what feedlot meat so when you
say well what happens when you feed
people regenerate meat or kangaroo meat
or
a wild elk i mean what is that going to
do so i think you know it's
it's also important understand that even
if we decided we want to eliminate
all meat you know 40 percent of the land
on the planet that we use for
agriculture is not suitable to grow
crops
which means you can only graze animals
and animals up cycle
nutrients that are inedible to humans
into the most nutritious
nutrient dense source of protein on the
planet so we you know if we want to feed
the planet we can't just say we're not
gonna
we're not gonna use those forty percent
of lands that are agricultural
because we don't wanna have animals it
just doesn't make sense
so i think in terms of how much protein
do we need what kind of protein do we
need
i think you know mixtures of animal
plant proteins are
fine i think if you if you're
exclusively plant based
it's harder to get adequate protein as
you age particularly with muscle mass
and the studies on this are very clear
there are very low levels of leucine
which is a rate limiting amino acid and
a few other important amino acids in
plant proteins where they're very high
in animal proteins and so when you look
at muscle building and muscle mass as
these studies go forward
you can do it but you have to eat
enormous amounts you need to eat like
three four cups of beans
right nobody's gonna do that so to
compare to like you have to have two
cups of beans or three cups of beans to
have a six ounce piece of chicken or
fish right
and it and i think and and i think
people just aren't gonna be able to get
that and i think
that's what i worry about any even the
studies that show you know if you eat a
lot of protein early on it might turn on
aging faster genes if you look at the
when people hit a certain age if they
don't even have protein they're actually
going to age much faster
um there was there was a great uh great
there's a great professor uh professor
walter longo who's an aging expert
at i think he's at ucla and i've had him
on my podcast at doctor's pharmacy and
he
he um he said you know he yeah thank you
and he said he said uh you know there
was this woman emma morano who was a
someone he knew was an italian woman
because he's italian he was studying
aging
and she died at 117 years old and when
she was like a teenager her doctors
told her she was anemic and she needed
three eggs a day so she had three eggs a
day her whole life
and then he said when she was in her 90s
he told her she was kind of dwindling a
little bit
so you should eat a pound of meat a day
a pound of meat a day
and she'll have to be 117 years old now
that's an anecdote obviously but you
know i think
i think uh the the biggest disease of
aging is sarcopenia
which if people haven't heard of that it
basically means sarco means less
sorry sarco means muscle and pina means
less so you have less muscle
so you lose muscle you can see this as
people age they get you know flabby and
muscle loss so you could be 65 be the
same weight that you were when you're 25
and be twice as fat
because your muscle ends up looking like
you know a ribeye instead of a filet
mignon
right and that is bad for your health
it's bad for your hormones it causes
stress hormones to go up it makes your
testosterone go down if you're a guy it
makes you you have
all kinds of increased inflammation and
metabolic issues and blood sugar issues
so so it's really important to conserve
and preserve muscle it's one of the most
central things around aging
and i think i think people just
underestimate the importance of that and
you can only
do so much to exercise you need to
basically the exercise is sort of like
you know the the you know putting the
the flame on the fire but you need to
put the ingredients in the pan you need
to have the right quality protein
so i hope that answered your question
yeah no i i i
made more of them um i feel like i
remember
hearing about this difference in animal
proteins and
basically you know and maybe this came
from
david asprey and sort of the bulletproof
sort of you know
when that came along and him talking
about butter and how
you know the the butter that um comes
from a certain kind of cow
is inflammatory but this other certain
kind of cow is anti-inflammatory and so
that
plays right into what you said yes
absolutely like how do you as a consumer
how do you make that choice like what do
you how do you fit the good stuff
it's not what you eat it's what you're
eating ate right
so so if you're if you're growing
broccoli in a soil that's depleted and
the soil
the broccoli's diet is very poor the
broccoli is not going to be so healthy
if you're eating a feedlot cow that's
eating
corn silage and ground up animal parts
and skittles and who knows what else
chicken poop
uh probably not gonna be so healthy but
if you're eating a
cow that has been grazing on hundreds of
different species of medicinal plants
with phytonutrients and vitamins and
minerals
you know you're gonna it's gonna be
quite different so it's really about
what you're eating ate
and what and what soil it grew in and so
so i think
you know i sort of really love this
concept of becoming a regenitarian
to regenerate the earth and your health
through choosing foods that actually are
grown in a way that
is regenerative and i think that's not
something we all can do today because
there just
isn't enough of it you know organic is
certainly a better step
um but i think there you know whether
it's you know
sourcing things from your local
community support agriculture uh
groups there's there's community support
agriculture or csas where you can
work with local farms they'll drop off a
box of food your house or there's
something called misfits or imperfect
produce where you can order online they
drop off ugly i mean i got this ugly
potato but it's like perfectly fine or a
funny looking you know carrot or you
know it's like they're who cares what
they look like
we throw we throw out really 40 percent
of our food goes in the landfills not
just
you know because it's ugly but because
we wasted at the table and the grocery
stores and
so um you know we can really become
conscious about where our food
food is sourced from and the quality of
our food and i think you know if there
are one
guiding principle that i would have
people think about it's this
you know food is not just calories it's
actually information
right it's instructions it's like code
and you can upgrade or downgrade your
biological software with every bite
and so when you're eating you're not
just eating for energy
you're eating for medicine and the
animals know this like
if you take an animal and you put it on
a grassland it will forage and eat all
kinds of different plants it's not going
to just eat
the cookies right it's going to eat
everything to give itself all the things
it needs we've lost that connection to
nature
so like kids so my dogs are out walking
and they start eating the plants on the
side of the trail yeah
exactly yeah yeah they like the cat
might cast it they eat the grass
so the kids will do that if kids are
iron deficient
they will eat dirt right if
if people are eating junk food they are
eating more and more food
partly because it's addictive but also
because there's no nutrients in the food
and they're looking for nutrients in the
wrong place so you literally if you give
people
an unlimited amount of whole foods to
eat and an unlimited amount of processed
foods to eat
in a meal they only 500 calories more in
the processed foods
because they're just not getting the
nutrient and the satisfaction
so so just think about you know how you
how you look at the quality of the food
so
really you are changing every single
thing in your body not over
decades but literally in minutes by what
you eat you're changing your gene
expression your hormones your immune
system
your gut flora your microbiome you're
changing your brain chemistry literally
with every single bite
and so you you have to think about that
when you eat and go well
am i going to be turning on things that
can make me feel good or bad
and sometimes you'll make a bad choice
that's fine but you don't you know you
you just
just be like a gps you know just make it
next you turn and
get back on track don't beat yourself up
and yell at yourself but just you know
you're on track but you know it is the
most central thing that people out there
is that food is medicine it's not like
medicine
it literally is is medicine i've always
believed that
um where so where's the best place to
get
you know i'm thinking about most people
when they go to the grocery store and
you go to the organic section you think
this
is buying great food you know you buy
organic meat or
you know what's the best you know give
us give people some tips when they go to
the grocery store
yeah or even just say like if you can
meet is a farmer's market good like yeah
yeah
yeah yeah what's the hierarchy and how
do you get the good stuff
yeah that's a great question so i've
read a lot of books about this my last
one food fix talked about how to become
a vegetarian
and how to how do you make the choices
and i if you go online to
foodfixbook.com there's the food fix
action guide and there's 20 suggestions
of what to do it's everything from
where to order online to community sport
agriculture growing your own garden
thrive market for example is one of my
favorites you can get 25
to 50 off goods there for all whole
healthy food goods that you see at whole
foods for a very expensive price
you can go directly to farmers who are
gender farmers like
mariposa ranch and others where you can
buy directly from the farmers
and you can get you know if you if you
get a big freezer and maybe share with
your friends you can buy half a cow
and you can get it for eight bucks a
pound for a gin of meat which is less
per serving than mcdonald's hamburger
so search for regenerative farmers in
your area you could yeah
and you could go to farmer's markets
that you can buy from your local farmers
and you can you can you know
do these community sport agriculture
efforts and and that's just a great
place to start and then you can
you know talk to your local grocery
store about you know sourcing more
locally
so there are ways to do it it's not easy
it's not perfect but it'll grow
well you can spend money on your health
now or you can spend it later when you
feel like crap
and you have to spend all that money
because you're you know in a hospital so
to pick your poison right that's true
you know or spend it later
well you know you know uh dennis it's
not just the money
people understand that they they lose
the quality of their life
totally the quality of your life is
everything it's how you
engage with the things that you love and
care about can you
show up in your relationships fully can
you enjoy
your body and being out in nature and
doing what you want can you can you do
the work you want to do in the world can
you fulfill your purpose can you be a
volunteer
and be of service i mean if you feel
like crap nobody wants to run around and
help
anybody else just want to sit on the
couch and watch netflix so
we talk about presenteeism we talk about
you know this phenomenon of you know
being at the job but not being on the
job because you feel like crap
these things are terrible and they
deprive us of enormous amounts of
of social economic and spiritual capital
that
that is is really unnecessary if we just
focus
on restoring our own health and that
helps us then restore our community's
health and it just
becomes a ripple effect i i'm so glad
you said that
i i think that's really true
another aspect of protein that i have
consumed
really my whole life and i would imagine
a lot of people have and that's um
protein powders so i
i have this idea i i mean in my mind i'm
like okay it's protein but i also have
this lurking feeling like
not really well it depends on what
right so i actually uh you know
have used the monologue over the years
and i think that you know it's it's
again like anything what are the
ingredients where do they come from
where they sourced are they whole are
they processed you know for example you
have
soy protein you know you're getting
isolated soy protein which is a waste
product from making soybean oil that's
extracted in a way that alters the
protein structure and makes it
carcinogenic
and inflammatory and you think oh i'm
getting soy protein shake well it's
terrible you know
but you know there's pea protein shakes
which may be better but again how was it
grown was it organic is it full of
pesticides
what was the soil like and and then what
are the other ingredients there's a lot
of sugars or a lot of additives
chemicals
you know it's hard i actually i was so
frustrated with the shakes that i
created my own which is made of you know
real ingredients like hemp seeds and
pumpkin seeds and pea protein and just
like
real food is this what's in the um the
10-day reset that you have
yeah it's the pagan shake the peak and
shake and i it's just so delicious
yeah because i'm like made so much fun
about this diet wars you know
everybody's a
paleo vegan and everybody's fighting
everybody and the truth is everybody
if you look at the people who are
focused on health and food
they agree on like 90 of everything we
should all eat whole foods we shouldn't
need processed foods we shouldn't
you know we should eat you know whole or
not not uh you know ideally
organic we should be having all these
chemicals in our food i mean it's all
the same
you know the only thing that's different
between pale you and vegan is where you
get your protein
everything else is the same even no
dairy so i think it's just you know it's
just kind of ironic so i said well
you know i was on a i was on a panel
with a friend of mine it was a paleo
doctor another one was a vegan
cardiologist and they were fighting
i'm like if you're paleo and you're
vegan i must be pagan and the whole
audience laughed i'm like oh this is
good i'm gonna use that
and so i basically created i created
this
article which kind of went viral and it
ended up in like
you know la times washington post and
telegraph in the uk
and like usa today i'm like what is
going on here
and i'm like it's the hottest new diet
trend i'm like it was a joke
well uh i'm on it um i'm on your train
your peak and
i think that's brilliant it's just it's
just it just it just takes out all the
extremism
and puts in common sense and science and
gets us agreeing on what we should be
doing because
they all have far more in common with
each other than they do with the
standard american diet that's the enemy
right it's not it's not each other it's
you know
like you're going to be vegan great if
you want to eat pale you're fine let's
focus on the real issue which is
what the rest of america is eating which
is 60 of our diet is ultra processed
foods that's the problem
i always feel like i was just talking to
my friend about this the other day we
went down to a little farmer's market
and we picked up some you know
tomatoes and some you know farm fresh
eggs they're of course colorful
and all kinds of other good stuff and i
was like man i
feel like if people could just wrap
their head around the idea of sourcing
food that's made by the sun like
oh is your box of cereal made by the sun
no
maybe you should eat it right oh is this
banana made by the sun
yeah that's probably a better option is
that a good one
a good way to think of it i think it's a
great way i you know i i used to do a
lot of lectures in churches
and i try to make it really simple and
previously it's really simple
leave the food that man made and eat the
food that god made
did god make a twinkie no did god make
an avocado
yeah it's pretty simple even a kid in
kindergarten can figure that one out
so i think that's a really simple
principle and i you know i just try to
have food
in my fridge and food in my cupboard and
sometimes i have packaged foods
but it's it's like a a jar of roasted
red peppers or a can of sardines or
you know a bag of nuts or you know
sometimes it's like i might
cheat and get like a bag of you know
pre-cooked lentil curry but it's all
real ingredients
right so i think i think as long as
you're reading the ingredient list
forget the nutrition facts label because
that's confusing but read the
ingredients and if there's anything in
there you wouldn't actually have in your
cupboard
you shouldn't eat it like if it has
butylated hydroxytoluene
would you have that and sprinkle that on
your salad every night no you don't have
that on your cupboard but it's in most
processed food right which you have
maltodextrin probably not you know
so so if you see any things that you
don't recognize or you literally don't
have
in a jar or something in your cupboard
don't eat it
i have one that i'm really curious about
i wasn't going to ask anything too too
specific but what about citric acid
because i feel like i've read that it's
mold
is this true i mean no citric acid is
uh is is like a as it comes like lemons
and
you know citrus food and it's it's a
preservative that can be used to help
sort of preserve food it's it's not one
of the worst ones no
okay good well you just opened me back
up to other items now so that's good
um you'd mention obviously like have
real food
and so that kind of leads to the final
aspect of the of
of you know our diets that i feel like
there's so many questions around and
you know one of sugar and you know
fruit's natural
right and so how what's your perspective
or what's
how much of that should we be eating and
should we be avoiding it all together if
possible
well here's the thing you know we we as
hunter-gatherers would
really have a hard time finding sugar
you know we'd get a honey thing or we'd
find some berries we
maybe we'd have 22 teaspoon equivalents
of sugar a year
now we have 22 teaspoons a day and some
a lot more kids have 34
and the average intake of sugar is about
152 pounds per person per year
and if flour it's about 133 pounds and
and they are equivalent so below the
neck your body can't tell a piece of
bread from a bowl of sugar
same thing i mean actually the bread's
worse when it comes to glycemic index
the bread is a hundred sugar is 80. so
[Music]
because it's so highly pulverized and
broken down that it just quickly
absorbed
so i think it's a problem uh so i think
you know
like you think about um oats and how
there's like quick cook
then there's steel cut right and then it
gets all the way to like
you know steel cut right so it's very
kernel that you have to cook for a
really long time
oats yeah right like is that kind of you
know
the way to think about it is like the
more pulverized becomes exactly
the bigger the more yeah high glycemic
you know
you eat a wheat berry don't eat the weed
you know
eat brown rice only brown rice flour and
i think uh we we really have
have overburdened our biologies with
sugar and we're not adapted to it which
is why we see one in two people with
pre-diabetes which is why we see
75 are overweight is because about 60
of our calories is this starchy sugary
food and that is driving insulin levels
high
and insulin is the hormone that makes
your
blood sugar going your cells but it also
makes you store belly fat
it drives inflammation it causes cancer
heart disease dementia
obviously diabetes it is it is the
driver of aging
so the whole key to successful aging and
health is to keep your insulin levels
low
and the best way to do that is by eating
a whole foods diet is by cutting out as
much starch and sugar as you can
you know and that includes things like
tons of white starchy potatoes have a
little
uh peruvian potatoes those are okay
because they're not so starchy
sweet potatoes sweet potatoes are fine
and it depends on your metabolic health
so if you're like you you're an athlete
you're healthy
but if you're if you're metabolically
unhealthy you're not a resilient
so you're not metabolically resilient so
so you can't
withstand the stress of that right so
you could
your body could withstand the stress of
being in a race car and going bazillion
miles around the
racetrack but you know just took some
somebody who's really out of shape and
would never exercise and was
300 pounds in the race car it would be a
bad situation
they're not they couldn't handle it so
you know if you are
in an athlete or if you're active and
you're fit you can tolerate more
freedom in your diet you can have more
starch you can maybe have a little more
sugar
if you're diabetic no i mean for my
diabetic patients we put them on
ketogenic
diets which means not only you know
sugar but you know down to
like less than five percent of their
calories is carbohydrates
and seventy percent is fat and they're
reversing diabetes within a year and
sixty percent of patients
like reversing it gone no sugar issues
no insulin
no medications it's radical and this is
really
great published data so i think i think
we really have to sort of look at
where you are in that metabolic health
spectrum metabolic resiliency and
flexibility and if you know if you're
someone who's exercising every day and
you're you know if you ride your bike 50
miles yeah go ahead and have like you
know some sugar
uh fruit fruit is okay for most people
again if you're really not metabolically
resilient
you know you're eating a lot of fruit it
may it may drop spike your blood sugar
so it's really about where you are in
that spectrum are you better off with
fruit
or well should you just look at the
glycemic level
of an ingredient i mean it's also what
you eat it with right so if you have
um let's say uh something with protein
and fat along with fruit
you know right if you for example you
have a glass of right you have a glass a
smoothie of fruit but if you're throwing
some protein and fat it's gonna slow
down the absorption it's gonna lower the
glycemic load of the meal
it'll make your blood sugar not spike as
much
okay i mean like i totally don't have
enough time with you
um so i can do a part two oh that'd
be great um and maybe i should maybe i
should i because i really want to ask
about other modalities too i want to ask
about
sleep meditation fasting
exercise again totally don't have enough
time so maybe we should maybe we should
just keep this on food and
and some other time we can do that um
so let me ask about kids so i know
obesity is a huge issue
especially in kids there's you know
billions of dollars spent on
advertisements to kids and of course
they're susceptible to the beautiful
colorful
ad that makes them look like they're
going to have so much fun eating
whatever it is that they're being
presented
but kids inevitably get tall
right they grow they get tall they you
know grow limbs and they get smarter and
all this stuff happens and so
you know kind of no matter what you feed
your kid they're going to do that
right like you can feed them fruit
roll-ups and cereal every day
and they're still going to grow so
they'll grow up and they'll grow out ah
explain that
well they'll grow tall but they'll grow
fat too oh yeah
but some i mean yeah i guess it's the
same syndrome as adults it's skinny fat
sometimes but
you know they can grow fat fat i mean 40
of kids are overweight
40 so this is a pandemic of obesity in
kids
so what i guess the question is is how
do we
like how do you make a decision as a
parent what is the
what awareness should they have about
feeding their children like
does it all matter what you feed them
now
just as much as it matters later or are
kids kind of like oh whatever their kids
they eat that
no no no one of the studies that just
blew me away was well a couple things
one was
the bogalusa heart study which looked at
children and followed children very
young and
followed them throughout their life over
many decades and they found that kids
who ate junk food and processed food had
you know starting to have like
pre-diabetes pre-hypertension
you know early like seven
eight nine years old and they could tell
that they were seeing fatty streaks in
these kids arteries even before they
were
out of their childhood and that these
kids then ended up having high
risk of heart attacks and strokes and
death because of their diets when they
were younger
and we know from epigenetics and from
what happens in the you in the u
in the uterus in the womb that the kids
who actually
are born to mothers who eat horrible
food have all the genes turned on that
program them for obesity and diabetes
and heart disease and even cancer so it
absolutely matters
and i think you know the most important
thing you can do
i mean the most important thing you can
do for your your kids is to start
early in in your home by making your
home a safe zone
you know you can't protect them from
everything out there but for a while
you know my kids they only ate what i
cooked i made them lunch
and made them dinner i made them
breakfast we had a garden
i got them in the kitchen i got i got
them in the kitchen my
i have a video from once like my son's
like one year well 13 14 months old in
the kitchen making a mess making
you know some flower thing and my
daughter cooking and
and we got them cooking and being part
of the food
when we went we took i took them the
grocery store we went grocery shopping i
showed them how to grocery shop
we grew a garden they went in the
gardens they helped plant the seeds
so they by the time like you know yeah
they made me go and eat junk food and
rebel a little bit like you know my
daughter did that in high school my son
did it
but then they come back and now they're
you know they're really healthy focused
uh and my son's a chef and my my
daughter's going to medical school and
they're
really focused on healthy cooking and
eating so i think
you know if you haven't done that it's
never too late to start
but i think it's really important to
make your home a safe zone with your
kids
and teach them about food and teach them
to read labels and
you know one time my son brought his
friends over he said
dad there's nothing to eat in the house
you know i got a bunch of teenage boys
there's nothing to eat can we go
can we go shopping like sure we can go
shopping and get what you want i said
there's one rule
you can't buy anything with trans fat
nothing no trans fat
he he literally couldn't find anything
to buy like everything had trans fat the
pizzas to this that everything was full
of trans fat
you know now it's not it's been ruled as
not safe to eat by the government
uh but it's still out there in foods um
yeah well it's i feel like there's just
there's just so much compromise being
made and i tend to be on the regimented
side of things and
a little bit stiff in my in my in my
diet and what i do
but you know i kind of believe that
you're either adding or reducing to your
wellness
like one of the other i almost don't
feel like there's a middle ground
yeah well i think you know think about
like if you're really resilient
you know how how you can bounce back
right so i think if
if i think about this is a metabolic
degrees of freedom if you if you create
a really robust health
then if you you know you have a little
you know uh sugar
one day it's not gonna kill you right
your body can handle it it's you know
but it but it but if you're if you're
like another if you're
if you're a wellness athlete let's call
it then you can withstand
lots of stresses that other people
couldn't now you don't want to do that
for a long time or over a long period of
time
but you know it's okay if you want to
have a glass of wine or if you want to
you know have a piece of cake or
something like i i don't make people
be fanatic because i think it's you know
unless they want to
it's it's not necessary but if you're
you know 90 of the time or more
focused on and by the way when i see
something sweet or whatever i'm talking
about a real whole food
make your own cookies from scratch you
know make them you know maybe make them
from
ingredients like i have my cookbooks
like almond flour and coconut flour so
they're higher in protein and
they don't have gluten and don't and
have other kinds of sugars use dates you
know so there's
there's ways to make things that are
dessert like
without creating a problem now i make
ice cream which which is basically
taking
frozen blackberries and i throw it in a
blender with some coconut milk and
you know a little vanilla and you know
you can even put a drop of honey in
there and it's like delicious people
don't know
when it's delicious like it's like
sorbet so i think you can you can really
uh hack sweet things in ways that
actually make them healthy
but but i don't think we should you know
feel like oh you have to be a
ascetic in a monk and you can't ever let
you know one drop of sugar past your
lips
because that's that's you know sweet
things are good
true and i think that that's what um you
know learning how to cook is a really
good way
to you know take care of your own health
as well as know how to deal with being
outside of your house
like knowing what ingredients are what
knowing
knowing how things are prepared when you
go into restaurants
because you've done it at home and
you're like wait that doesn't yeah that
on my lips that's oil that's a lot of
fat on those
vegetables or or whatever it is it gives
you a much better indication
of what you're experiencing outside so
um
okay i'm going to skip over all the all
the fun modalities outside
all the fun ways that we can take care
of ourselves outside of
just food itself and um you know what's
uh
i mean you know one thing i'm really i
do want to ask about is
you have a wellness center the ultra
wellness do i do i have a practice
on the horizon and i feel like this is
like part of it because even i was
thinking to myself with um
i was gonna ask with i feel like i don't
even know if i can trust certifications
on labels just because it's organic or
just because it's this or that
does the us usda certified or whatever
what does that really mean
and should maybe that's the first
question do we need to create a whole
new
approval system well i mean usda's
organic
certification does mean something and
there are you know there are
certifications that mean something and i
talk about them for example for fish for
animal products for poultry and like
what the different organizations are
that will verify
whether or not it's okay or not uh or if
it's better for you
um there's a new certification that's
being put forth which i really love it's
called regenerate regenerative organic
certification
which is new uh and i think that that
needs to get pushed forward because that
just raises the bar a little bit
and then it pushes the people more and
more into that space agreed that's
awesome
um when do you think we'll start seeing
that can we see that in stores now
label uh not not yet i don't think but
soon i hope
yeah all right well what's the ultra
wellness center then
well i've had a practice for 15 years in
lex massachusetts which is
treating people from all over the world
for chronic complaints that are
addressed through functional medicine
which is really the science of creating
health and we treat
the body and the system we don't treat
the disease it's really like
being a soil farmer as opposed to
growing you know soybean and
you know putting all these chemicals and
fertilizers like as a drug
example uh it's more like being a
regenerative farmer
as a doctor and i help regenerate human
health through removing those things
that cause problems and adding those
things that
that create health and that leads to
people getting better from all sorts of
chronic issues not just
obesity and diabetes but autoimmune
disease and neurologic diseases
and digestive issues and mood issues i
mean there's really so much that can be
helped with functional medicine and
we're doing all our business virtually
now we have you know very
large group of doctors and nutritionists
and and great team and so we now are
doing all telemedicine so you don't
matter where you are in the world we can
still take care of you
do you see that well you know we
we did expand i mean during covert we've
seen a real uptick in our in our
business
it's just um yeah because people don't
travel and they don't
go anywhere and they can see me like
this on zoom and we can have a great
conversation and and people feel great
so it's a whole new technology of
telemedicine and uh and i think you know
i i don't know how big we want to grow
but i think we're doing a great job of
taking care of
really amazing people i also have the
center for functional medicine at
cleveland clinic which i run
which is a great resource for people as
well so um and then go to
ultrawellnesscenter.com learn more about
our work
uh and it's pretty fun because uh we get
people from you know people who are
extremely sick
at the very end of the spectrum disease
to people who just want to be super
athletes and healthy and
live to be 120 so anywhere in that
spectrum we really help people
how can someone find um how can someone
find a functional
doctor well they can go to
a website called functionalmedicine.org
sorry um no it's ifm.org so it'll be
ifm.org
which is the institute for functional
medicine and
and there is a tab that's called find a
practitioner tab
and you can search for one in your area
who's been certified and that'll give
you a start
it doesn't tell you you know like for us
we have you know 60 70 years of
collective experience they might have
one
right so it doesn't tell you how
experienced they are but you know the
ultra wellness center again is available
to everybody
that's a great resource so yeah amazing
all right well can you send us off with
um
you know like a top five list of the
most um
what what can we eat that would make us
feel
better every day well i think it's
really simple i mean i i i feel bad that
i i make my career out of something so
obvious and simple but it's really
eat real food right if if it didn't
you know come from a plant don't eat in
other words if it wasn't eating a plant
or come from a
literally a plant not grown not made in
a plant you should eat that's what
michael pollan says so eat real whole
foods
second is don't eat ultra processed food
don't eat stuff that
is full of all these weird ingredients
full of hormones antibiotics pesticides
tons of sugar starch i mean just get rid
of that stuff from your diet eat real
food
second is increase the amount of plant
foods you eat eat
75 percent of your plate has non-starchy
vegetables
um which which are you can eat in
unlimited quantities like you want to
eat 14 cups of broccoli go right ahead
you know
you will promise you'll get full and i
usually have two or two or three or four
different vegetable dishes
every night so i don't just have one
like you know like
a protein in like one vegetable i have
like a lot of vegetables and a little
bit of protein
and i think you know eat good quality
fats also people are afraid of fat and
they think that makes them fat
but the olive oil avocados nuts and
seeds these good fats
are so important and if you can tolerate
them some things like mct oil coconut
oil this can be helpful ghee
grass-fed butter these can be fine even
animal fats are fine
for a lot of people if they're not
eating them with starch and sugar so the
caveat is if you're eating a lot of
starch and sugar
and you have saturated fat it's dead so
don't do that
um and then and then you want to what
does that mean like an apple and peanut
butter and apple and that's fine
that's fine that's fine it's more like
you know bread and butter don't do that
right right if you eat saturated bread
and butter that's a deadly combo
a cookie ice cream those are deadly
gamblers french fries deadly
you know so i think uh and then you know
we just we just have to understand that
that uh
our our bodies are are incredible um
organisms that can heal and repair and
if we provide the
right ingredients and we take out the
bad ingredients and so just following
these simple principles and i
am coming up with a book in next
february called the pagan diet which is
kind of a joke about the principles but
it's
basically like 20 20 something uh
principles for for eating in a
nutritionally confusing world and i just
try to break it down
and tell people to say look these are
the simple things and you know you don't
have to be perfect but
these are these these are like guard
rails right these are not you know
absolute rules yeah amazing well
congratulations on all your success 13
time best seller
new york times the best best-selling
author like you you're
you're helping millions and millions of
people all over
the world um you know get healthy
so take care regenerate the soil can
regenerate
it can all be well exactly it's all
about regenerating and rebuilding our
our communities ourselves our nation i
mean we're in a time rebuilding and i
think
this time of code is a giant time out to
put go in our rooms and think about what
we did wrong and
figure out how to do it right i love
that
thank you okay take care thanks
everybody for listening to the pretty
intense podcast today i hope you enjoyed
it
if you like what you heard today and you
want to hear more please click
on the subscribe button